all right we're going to talk about 2023
some things that I've seen uh changes in
divorce laws some things you ought to
know about now Florida leads the way so
far two major changes in Florida divorce
law it's 2023. uh the first is no more
permanent alimony in Florida used to be
you're in a long-term marriage and you
were slam dunk for permanent alimony for
the rest of your life they abolished
that they still have alimony but it's
different types of alimony whether it's
rehabilitative alimony to get your ex up
on our feet or his feet or uh you know
Bridge the alimony so they can find a
place to live but no more permanent
alimony and that is a huge step in the
right direction
until death then so if he was paying
alimony to her when he died that's when
it would stop
if he was paying alimony to her and he
died
if her lawyer was smart they would have
had him uh by court order have a life
insurance policy for a million dollars
at least so she would so even if she put
him into the grave and he had a heart
attack and died she's still going to get
a payout in case uh he died quickly
after the divorce so hopefully doing of
uh Governor DeSantis well here's the
final say he could have vetoed it but
it's actually the Florida House of
Representatives and uh so somebody takes
up this clause and says this is crazy
you know the constituents are saying
look we're going to elect you but we
want you to Champion this bill in the
House of Representatives so it makes its
way all the way through the house they
voted in and it's up to DeSantis to sign
the bill or not and he signed it so
that's a huge step in the right
direction for ambitious people who may
have made a mistake or got divorced
through no fault of their own or choice
and they don't have to pay lifetime
alimony anymore so yeah it seems like it
seems like such a bad deal like there's
still quite a few States out there where
you know you can get married and be
married for you know the required period
of time as a state outlines uh for
lifetime alimony it's like you're
continuing to pay for a woman that
you're not even intimate with or
involved with or receiving any benefit
from it's just it's completely absurd
you know because we have this like
modern era of of women and feminism and
I don't need no man or woman needs a man
like a fish needs a bicycle but she sure
is happy as hell to take his uh you know
or reap the financial rewards for into
perpetuity really right
yeah what I see a lot of is uh even so
someone that's in their 50s let's say
and the wife wants she's bored or you
know she's attracted to the pool boy and
she might have an affair with him or she
might find somebody else that
she wants to be with
no fault divorce files for divorce and
then if it's a long-term marriage she
could get alimony for years and what if
the husband in his 60s or 70s and he
wants to retire and he's got to pay this
alimony he's got to go back to court and
convince the judge look I'm of
retirement age I can't keep paying her
and live so it's a mess so I'm a big fan
of what they did in Florida in terms of
no more lifetime alimony you know if you
a lot of people they'll parachute out of
a marriage and maybe get millions of
dollars in equitable distribution I why
do they even need alimony at that point
you know it seems to me like if the
system needs to be changed the whole
marriage and alimony system is way out
of whack especially since there's a lot
of women in the workplace who make a lot
of money too so is there a is there a
website
um that grades the states based on uh
like Father friendliness I know that
there's that there's the national that
the there's a national org of parents
Association or something like that I had
them on about a year a year and a half
ago and and they grade it for like um uh
access to kids and child support
um fairness but I haven't seen one that
grades it overall you know as far as
like friendliness to men
I don't know of a website that grades it
there's so many criteria a lot of times
it comes down to the specific Judge you
could be in the same county and go
across the hall to a different judge's
courtroom and they have a different view
of what's fair and the problem for a lot
of people is
judges uh decisions in Family Court are
subject to the abuse of discretion
standard which means that you have the
burden to prove that the decision they
made was uh they abused their discretion
now there's exceptions to that where the
standard is uh did they go outside the
bounds of the law but if it's like a
child custody decision or an alimony
decision
you're going to have a hard time
overturning it you have to prove by your
preponderance of the evidence that you
know the decision was just way out of
line and that's hard to do but
um I did see a website a long time ago
where they tried to grade the states
regarding uh men's rights with child
custody and that is a great segue into
the next area of law that was changed
very recently again in the State of
Florida uh the State of Florida
passed their house bill 1301 I have a
copy of it here
um here so I've got I've got his talking
notes here so I'm going to just hope
that he gets back in in time but uh
Florida's new child custody law defaults
to 50 50 custody with a rebuttal
presumption against it it's a huge win
for Dad's Law was sponsored by a 40 year
old woman elected to the Florida House
of Representatives Jenna Parsons
I'm probably pronouncing that completely
wrong but that's interesting that a
woman tabled this
um law
um but if you guys aren't familiar
um
default 50 50 custody is exceptionally
uh rare uh there's only a few places in
the west where if you get divorced it's
it's presumed that the children or the
child will be with both parents on a 50
50 schedule
um the burden of perform sorry the
burden of proof then becomes on if the
parent wants
um and it might mess this up a little
bit and Jonathan will clarify you know
when he gets back in but
the parent that wants to be the primary
caregiver the the custodial parent
basically has to prove uh that the other
parent is essentially a piece of trash
um they would have to prove something
along the lines that they're a drug
dealer they're a criminal they're you
know they're a felon they uh traffic uh
uh you know whatever or maybe even
prostitution you know might be involved
in something like that but they would
have to prove all of these things
um for the 50 50 to be set aside
Jonathan sorry man we lost you froze I
don't know if that was your internet uh
yeah I think just for a second and I
apologize for that I I'm not sure what
you've picked up uh in my absence you
held up the piece of paper and then you
froze from there so it's like all right
so I just went through your talking
points and I sort of tried to explain
what what default shared 50 50 was right
um so I don't want to be redundant but
the special thing about this bill is
it defaults to 50 50 as opposed to
places like Pennsylvania
where the law says
gender shall not uh it doesn't matter it
should not be part of the decision they
take it a step further in Florida now
and they said it's default 50 50 uh with
a rebuttable presumption that it
shouldn't be 50 50. that is huge so if
you go to a website and you look at
um uh father friendly jurisdictions look
at the law itself and read the law now
you might think to yourself what could
somebody argue where it wouldn't be 50
50 and one common thing is if the
parents live too far apart from each
other and the kid uh goes to a public
school most judges are not going to let
the kids sit in too much windshield time
like if it's an hour to drive them to
school every day and back especially if
they're in grade school or middle school
that's a reason where you got to be
careful and it's not based on mileage
you could uh live in Hoboken New Jersey
and try to get your kid to school in
Manhattan that's only a few miles apart
but they're going to look and see if
it's in the best interest of the kid but
if you live in the same school district
and I know in many jurisdictions
Pennsylvania included that the bus if
your kid goes to a public school and
they take the bus if you live in the
same school district or a certain
mileage from the school the bus company
has to pick the kid up from the other
parent's house on the days that they
have custody so I tell my clients give
the bus company a copy of your custody
schedule and let them know that on these
days you're going to pick up the kid
from this house and on the other days
from the other house
because I was because I was talking
about it a bit when your screen froze up
um would it be reasonable for a parent
to argue
um to be the custodial parent or to be
the sole sole caregiver in a state where
it's default 50 50 like it is in Florida
now
um prostitution felony drug dealer like
under what circumstances could a parent
say
that other parent is a piece of [__] and
they shouldn't uh and we shouldn't have
a shared 50 schedule aside from distance
you know with buses and stuff like that
right that's a great question all right
so it's not only the other parent's
character but it's the other parent's
new paramours character too in places
like Pennsylvania so there's a list of
enumerated offenses that you've either
been charged with if the charges are
pending or you've been convicted or pled
guilty to one big one is reap r-e-a-p uh
recklessly endangering another person
that's serious anything that has to do
with child endangerment
that yeah you got a a huge uphill
headwind climb uh to convince the court
that you should have equally shared
custody you might even depending upon
what the crime was and how long ago it's
going to be tough
um anything that has to do with sexual
assault all right anything that has to
do with domestic violence that's why
false domestic violence charges you got
to fight them a lot of times people make
false accusations and that could affect
your custody if you plead guilty or
convicted so
any of those kind of violent
um you know of course homicide murder in
the first second or third degree you
have an uphill climb but
you'll still get some visitation but
there's gonna have to be a third party
there usually without a criminal record
the per the third party uh I mean there
are guys in prison where they'll take
the kid on visitation day to see the
parent so you don't lose all custody and
contact unless you don't have any
interest but if you got the right lawyer
you're gonna have
uh some contact and that's physical
custody legal custody as it's defined in
most jurisdictions that I'm familiar
with is the right to
oh crap yeah and uh that should always
that's almost always 50 50 in
Pennsylvania
uh unless one person's incarcerated and
they can't make those decisions because
you can't get to them so uh you should
if you're a parent and you want to be in
your child's life and make those
decisions educational decisions in
places like Pennsylvania they don't just
give one parent carte blanche to make
all those decisions uh other
jurisdiction say too I just want to
emphasize the significance and the
importance of a default 50 50
parenting plan if you have to untie them
out
like I have a friend he's he's here
right now and
I thought that he was recently divorced
right like he's still fighting
and I said to him
it'll get better and he looked at me
with crazy eyes like what because it's
been nine years he's been fighting for
nine years
since his kid was basically a a toddler
with his ex-wife
um over parenting schedules custody
Arrangements holidays birthdays
Christmases you name it even to take a
couple of days off to meet up with the
boys and go for a road trip and just do
something fun as a man he's still
fighting on this because in Ontario in
Canada you don't have a default 50 50
Arrangement like you do in some states
now introduced in Florida it's my
opinion and my recommendation to guys
that if you are going to get married and
tie a knot with somebody and have
children my recommendation is move to a
state that is Father friendly with a 50
50 default shared custody plan because
it removes one of the most contentious
parts of divorce that I've seen happen
to most guys in Ontario that's where
most of my friends live Jonathan what do
you think about that
I think it's a good idea a lot of times
people though are tethered like if you
started a business that's location
dependent yeah it's big to pick up and
move to a state where you don't know
anybody and you don't have your support
system
uh so now Florida just instituted this
hopefully other states will pick up on
it I know that they looked at this in
Pennsylvania about 10 years ago and it
was shot down and
I I disagree with shooting it down why
if this person was good enough for you
to make a child with why are they now
not good enough for you to be half
parent you know have them half the time
now some jurisdictions including
Pennsylvania have parent coordinators
because the judges just can't take every
single little fight that the parents
have so they'll uh appoint a parenting
coordinator and the parents pay this
person by the hour it's a licensed
attorney that has training and
experience in resolving these fights
because the courts have other things to
do not fight over whether you know
Little Johnny's getting pizza with
pepperoni on it or not you know and you
can imagine or maybe you can like when
people get angry and bitter they put the
kids in the middle and it it hurts the
kids
it's crazy you know uh people just can't
get over being a co-parent uh but
hopefully your friend after all these
years eventually the other side will
just like either come to their senses or
run out of gas or run out of money and
say this isn't working because as the
kids get older they're hip to this you
know they know what's going on and they
know the parents that's stirring the pot
all the time but people don't listen and
uh they'll burn I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full-length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out